it's a shame what's happened with the
FBI but we're gonna rebuild the FBI
it'll be bigger and better than ever but
it is very sad when you look at those
documents and how they've done that is
really really disgraceful and you have a
lot of very angry people that are seeing
it it's a very sad thing to watch I will
tell you that and I'm going today on
behalf of the FBI their new building and
you know but when I wouldn't everybody
not me when everybody the level of anger
as what they've been witnessing with
respect to the FBI is certainly very sad
all right that was the president earlier
today before he departed for the FBI's
National Academy in Quantico Virginia
where he spoke at a graduation ceremony
for law enforcement officials for for
the United States of America and around
the world the president is rightfully
upset with some of the blatant bias
being shown by top ranking officials now
rank-and-file at the FBI and the DOJ
just to be clear we've said this many
times we do have great respect for those
men and women of law enforcement in our
country who save us every day and put
their lives on the line and we know the
president feels the same way here's what
he said earlier today it's an honor to
stand here today with the incredible men
and women of law enforcement I am here
not only to congratulate you but to
honor you for your courage and for your
devotion and I want you to know that
with me as your president America's
police will have a true friend and loyal
champion in the White House more loyal
than anyone else can be now with
reaction Fox News national security
strategist former deputy assistant to
the president sebastian Gorka and
investigative reporter Sarah Carter you
know it's so sad because if you have one
bad cop you know people want to use that
what we forget about the 99.9 percent
same with the FBI same with intelligence
officials those that work hard to
protect us put their lives on the line
every day Sarah well when you have the
head of the FBI James Comey working with
Peter struck and they're riding in X
honor
raishin of Hillary Clinton before they
do their investigation that's not equal
justice under the law Peter struck who
thinks for some reason God appointed him
to save the country
and that they are they're building
insurance policies in case Trump wins
this is corruption I think at the
highest level we've ever seen your
reaction well yeah I mean I've talking
to field agents today a number of field
agents and retired FBI agents and they
have the same sentiment as President
Trump
remember people want to criticize
President Trump but what we've seen on
the seventh floor it's something that
we've never seen before and people have
said this over and over again never seen
this type of behavior within the FBI
which is so blatant and you know Shawn
what was even more interesting to me was
they were telling me they were at an
event all of these field agents and some
military officials were there and they
said everybody was worried about Russia
collusion with Trump instead what we're
seeing is FBI seventh-floor collusion
with Clinton's and that's how they're
feeling all right Sebastian Gorka I know
how you feel about law enforcement we
all feel the same way but this is real
collusion this is real corruption
there's no other way to describe what
Comey and Peter struck did the fix was
in the fix was in months before he did
his investigation to me if I'm James
Comey tonight I'm Peter struck tonight
I'm thinking I better hire the best
lawyers DC has shown Sarah's absolutely
right let me tell you my personal
experience I've worked closely with
thousands of agents and analysts I was
in the White House earlier this week for
the Christmas celebrations and so was
another retired agent from the FBI who
had at least 20 25 years in he
recognized me came up to me and he said
the bureau's reputation is short and
it's not because of the people who are
protecting us on the streets in the
Terrorism Task Forces it's because of a
handful of bad apples of bent cops
corrupt cops and so on the saddest thing
is we're getting the documents now and
I'm seeing emails of collusion
inside the FBI to protect Hillary
Clinton because they think she's the
next president and in a CC line I'm
seeing names of agents I highly
respected and had worked with who once
they got to the seventh floor Sean
that's it under the Obama administration
they became political hacks and it's
gonna take years to rebuild the FBI but
but the president said it today he's
going to rebuild it and he can rebuild
it it needs to be rebuilt and and the
same by the way top people former Obama
people within the intelligence community
before this is all said and done I
believe this house of cards false you
know your story yesterday about reverse
targeting the misuse of the powerful
tools of intelligence that we we give
the intelligence community that you
reported Sarah that doesn't even get
into the dossier issue bought and paid
for by Hillary with salacious Russian
propaganda lies to influence an
electorate that doesn't get into the
uranium one deal I'm not sure how we
untangle all of this and the best way to
do that your thoughts on it well I think
the best way to do that is one step at a
time
one story at a time Sean one
investigation at a time and that's what
we've done over the past year and that's
why we see this yarn unraveling peeling
back the onion as you always say one
layer at a time and now with you brought
up the dossier such a great point and we
see now that Bruce ORS wife was hired by
fusion GPS to help with the Stasi I mean
this is incredible stuff we would have
never discovered this had we not done it
one story at a time and I think we need
to continue that be very factual find
those facts present them to the American
public so that they know what's going on
and so that we can clean up our system
because this is still the greatest
country on Earth well we still have the
greatest system of intelligence is
misused yet people are paying people for
stories if dossiers from Russia are
being used if you know the misuse of
intelligence if literally we are
ignoring bribery kickbacks extortion and
money laundering and we get
20% of our uranium away and money's
thrown but none of there seems to come
to full resolution dr. Gorka oh it will
oh the the stories are just coming out
thanks to Sara thanks to John thanks to
you Sean but but sheriff thought no no
bed during the heavy lifting and you are
but but Sara is absolutely right she
stole my thunder we are the greatest
nation on God's earth we are also the
most powerful nation on God's earth
which means when you start to weaponize
law enforcement when you start to
politically weaponize the intelligence
community like John Brennan like the
last administration Eric Holder did it
is more dangerous than anything you can
imagine and that's why we have to step
in now people have to be investigating
prosecutors this separates us from a
police state if we don't get these
issues resolved and there's the deep
state illegally surveilling Americans we
shred the Fourth Amendment protections
of our Constitution we we're gonna lose
the country these this is not a game
what we're talking about here these are
severe violations of law and it all
needs to come to a head